die preise gingen gerade durch die decke
essen teurer tanken teurer heizen teurer
die inflation in deutschland erreicht
den höchsten stand seit fast 50 jahren
steil nach oben fast acht prozent das
ist völliger wahnsinn werden wir alle
ärmer oder steuert die politik dagegen
was tut denn die ampel überhaupt wir
haben den kinderbonus erhöht die
heizkostenpauschale hört die
einmalzahlung in höhe von 100 euro für
transferempfänger die energie pauschale
in höhe von 300 euro für alle
erwerbstätigen die einführung des 99
euro tickets wurde gesagt und die
senkung der steuern auf benzin und
diesel die höhen in der einkommenssteuer
dauerhaft und rückwirkend zum ersten
januar den grundfreibetrag der
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag und die
pendlerpauschale fehlt noch der höheren
mindestlohn anhebung der rente und so
weiter und so fort es gibt jetzt ja zwei
mega teure entlastungs pakete von etwa
30 milliarden euro nur helfen die den
richtigen ist es richtig jetzt rekord
schulden zu machen oder ist genau das
ungerecht für die nächste generation ins
politik schaut genau hin
[Applaus]
ich bin übrigens britta buchholz ich
schaue im zdf hauptstadtstudio vor allem
auf die finanzen und habe auch was mit
zahlen studiert nämlich bwl und deshalb
interessiert mich dieses thema und
gemeinsam schauen wir jetzt mal was die
ampel da so veranstaltet bevor es
losgeht müssen wir einmal klären was ist
inflation überhaupt und das ist gerade
für ärmere natürlich ein großes problem
stimme und vor wir gehen in den
supermarkt und haben einen euro dann
konnte man dafür bisher zwei pakete
günstige nudeln kaufen das ist jetzt
vorbei jetzt bevor man gerade noch mal
ein paket günstige nudeln und wenn es so
weiter geht bekommt man eben gar keine
nudeln mehr für einen euro und das ist
gerade für diejenigen die sowieso auf
jeden cent und euro schauen müssen ein
riesenproblem also bevor man sich die
maßnahmen genauer anguckt muss man sich
ja genauer ansehen wer überhaupt von der
inflation besonders betroffen ist
stellen wir uns mal an studenten
vorhersagen wer bafög satz 800 euro
davon gehen 4 100 euro fürs zimmer drauf
dann kommen noch lebensmittel obendrauf
sagen wir mal 200 sind es 600 euro oder
bleiben am ende noch 200 euro übrig und
von diesen 200 euro muss die kaputte
waschmaschine bezahlt werden dann kommt
noch das kaputte fahrrad doch der urlaub
dann kommt noch was auch immer sobald
die inflation zuschlägt ist es für
diejenigen besonders schwert die eben
ganz wenig haben das ist nicht nur bei
studenten so sondern auch bei rentnern
an der armutsgrenze oder
alleinerziehenden bei twitter gibt es ja
den hashtag ich bin armut betroffen
schaut euch den mal an denn diese
geschichten sind einfach erschüttert und
jetzt muss ich erst mal klarstellen die
ampel sie tut ja was aber viele beklagen
ist doch reine dies kann politik
dies kann im bild das ist jetzt gerade
so ein bisschen 80er jahre aber es
drängt sich einfach dieses bild auf
jeder bekommt geld aber die die wirklich
von der inflation betroffen sind die
bekommen dann eben zu wenig gerade im
mittelpunkt der aufmerksamkeit steht ja
der sogenannte tank rabatt
[Musik]
es ist ja kein geheimnis den wollte die
fdp um vor der kamera sagt der
parteivorsitzende lindner auch weiter es
wäre eine gute idee gewesen
ich bekenne mich dazu ich mache auch
etwas für autofahrerinnen und pendler
die haben alle anderen nicht im plan mir
ist das wichtig hinter der kamera
schütteln natürlich auch einige fdp
politikerin den kopf über die konzern
hat klar einerseits es sehr gut dass die
politik die probleme steigender
energiepreise ernst nimmt aber der
verdacht liegt ja nahe dass das geld
anderer reicher macht nämlich die
mineralölkonzerne
das hat auch lindners liebster
kabinettskollege verstanden das als
entlastung für die bürgerinnen und
bürger die verbraucher die verbraucher
gedacht war geht in die taschen der
großen mineralölkonzerne
dass man darüber sauer ist empört das
was nicht richtig sein kann ist völlig
klar tja und jetzt jetzt will habe
prüfen ob das kartellamt was tun könnte
es gibt übrigens auch wichtige
wirtschafts männer die das anders sehen
chef vom ifo-institut themen
fußballspiels weise der sagt bei twitter
die these die steuersenkung sei an die
mineralölkonzerne geflossen bestätigt
sich nicht im vergleich zu frankreich wo
es am ersten juni keine steuersenkung
gab sind die preise in deutschland bei
diesel um den betrag der steuersenkung
gefallen bei benzin um etwas weniger
soll heißen der tank rabatt bringt doch
etwas nur ob dieser rat überhaupt sinn
macht oder nicht das hat auch clemens
fuß schon ganz am anfang angezweifelt
ich halte das für eine falsche maßnahme
zum einen ist ja öl knapp das heißt wir
müssen alle öl sparen benzin sparen da
geben wir aber das signal das man eher
mehr verbraucht und da muss man sagen
haushalte mit hohem einkommen die haben
große autos die fahren mehr und
verbrauchen viel mehr benzin als
haushalte mit niedrigen einkommen die
die entlastung er brauchen das heißt
tank rabatt ist umverteilung von unten
nach oben die verteilungs effekte sind
also schlecht es ist insgesamt
ziemlicher quatsch der sogenannte tank
rabatt bedeutet für den staat drei
milliarden euro mindereinnahmen 3
milliarden aber der tank rabatt
unterstützt das team egal ob kleinwagen
oder suv das bedeutet erzählt eben nicht
auf die gruppe der ärmeren gerecht ist
an
[Musik]
beispiel 2 fangen wir mit einem kleinen
ratespiel an wer ist dieser mann der
bundesverkehrsminister der fdp trat noch
nicht so viel ins rampenlicht außer an
dem morgen als er das neun euro ticket
präsentierte und zwar ziemlich stolz
es gab so viele begeisterte anhänger des
99 euro tickets auf uns zu gekommen sind
und gesagt haben das mache ich werde den
öpnv ausprobieren und wenn es gut
funktioniert ist das für mich ehrlich
dauerhafte optionen zu pendeln das neun
euro ticket ein flop oder eintopf hilft
es denen die es brauchen entlastet es
autofahrer die nun günstig auf die bahn
umsteigen sind es wirklich die die jetzt
unterstützung brauchen und vor allem am
wochenende sind die züge jetzt richtig
voll studien zeigen der autoverkehr der
hat sich aber nicht spürbar verändert
der bund also wir alle zahlen
2,5 milliarden euro fast wieder drei
milliarden minimum aus den männern hören
wir sogar das soll noch mehr geld
fließen 3 milliarden für den tank rabatt
3 milliarden fast für das 9 euro ticket
und dann nochmal 30 milliarden sind das
insgesamt für die entlastungs paket dazu
100 milliarden für die bundeswehr also
wenn wir den taschenrechner nehmen dann
stellen wir fest ist es die zweithöchste
schuldenaufnahme des bundes 136
milliarden neue schulden
2022 die kolleginnen und kollegen vom
focus haben mal errechnet wie viel eine
familie mit zwei kindern aufgrund der
inflation jetzt mehr zeit
242 euro pro monat und das sind dann
etwa 3000 euro pro jahr im verhältnis
dazu sind neun euro ticket tank rabatt
einmalzahlungen beim kindergeld alles
tropfen auf den heißen stein deshalb
fordern einige aus spd und grünen jetzt
ein drittes entlastungspaket vor einem
halben jahr hätte auch keiner gedacht
dass wir 100 milliarden neue schulden
für ein sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr aufnehmen heute ist das der
stand der debatte und die mehrheit
findet das auch richtig und ich glaube
in der offenheit sollten wir auch auf
alles zu gehen was jetzt noch vor uns
liegt noch mehr schulden und das
bedeutet noch mehr für die junge
generation die in zukunft mit ihren
steuern eben diese schulden zurückzahlen
muss ist das gerecht lindner meint nein
er verweist immer wieder auf die
schuldenbremse für ihn ist die
einhaltung der schuldenbremse 20 23 ja
so was wie eine heilige kuh schafft er
das nicht ist er ja vielleicht weg vom
fenster ich glaube dass die menschen
unter inflation leiden troßbach wir
sehen umfragen dass die menschen in
sorge sind über die weitere
wirtschaftliche entwicklung ich teile
diese sorgen gut genau die inflation ist
das problem frau roßbach von der sz weiß
dass jetzt auch das macht der lindner
übrigens gerne journalisten verbessern
oder auch ihre beiträge korrigieren und
jetzt wollen wir herrn lindner
verbessern im juli 20 21 im
bundestagswahlkampf präsentierte sich
lindner als die idealbesetzung für den
posten des finanzministers credo mit mir
gibt es keine neuen schulden die
schuldenbremse ist die bei open source
die bindung an die solidität und die
interessen der nächsten generation das
lindner sich mit jigsaws vergleicht ist
übrigens irgendwie auch amüsant dennoch
düster ist der held der griechischen
mythologie war ja selbst zehn jahre auf
ihr vater aber es ist ja lindner der die
136 milliarden neuen schulden
mitverantwortet und das ist ja genau der
spagat die ärmsten treffen die preise
katastrophal und da liegt gefahr für die
ungerechtigkeit das ganze land kann noch
mehr in schieflage geraten doch odysseus
lindner kann ja schwerlich noch höhere
schuldenberge anhäufen oder was meint
ihr was würde überhaupt wirken gerade
die jung was ist gerechter jetzt ein
drittes entlastungspaket und der jungen
generation noch mehr aufbürden spürt ihr
die inflation profitiert ihr von den
politischen maßnahmen tank rabatt 9 euro
ticket sofort geld oder geht an euch
alles vorbei durch die gießkanne mein
fazit die ampel koalition will jedem
etwas geben aber subventionen für
jedermann das hilft eben nicht denen die
es am allermeisten brauchen nicht mehr
geld für alle sondern das richtige geld
für die richtigen